c'est un acteur qu'on dit en colère un
acteur qui ne joue pas pour ne rien dire
c'est beau acteur majeur du cinéma
français vincent lindon est connu pour
ses prises de position si on m'invite à
blain télévisés qu'on me parle on a
compris une question sur les situations
sont les sans papiers là je réponds à la
six est engagée ouija l'artiste engagé
engagé politiquement
en 1995 il soutient jacques chirac
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
pour la présidentielle de 2007 il monte
à la tribune pour soutenir françois
bayrou c'est après avoir ma vie que je
m'intéresse rapidement à la politique et
c'est la première fois que je suis
quelqu'un et je sais que j'ai du pif et
j'ai choisi le bon pas vraiment pu cette
fois-ci mais vous un peu plus en 2012 il
soutient alors la candidature de
françois hollande je voterai pour
françois mitterrand pour jacques chirac
et françois hollande je pense surtout
cdc des machines de guerre d énorme star
déjantée un charisme irrésistibles qui
ont quand même dans les grandes valeurs
les mêmes idées pour ce qui est de
l'humanitaire et des grandes choses de
la vie vincent lindon lui s'engage à
travers ses rôles à la fois vigiles
premier minitre ou syndicalistes c'est
son rôle de maître nageur qui vient en
aide un jeune migrant kurdes à calais
qui l'amène à débattre avec le ministre
de l'immigration eric besson en 2009 je
n'ai pas la prétention de ge de gérer
les flux migratoires mais j'ai la
prétention de de demander à nos
dirigeants de nous mettre dans une
position où on apparaît comme un pays
digne et qu'on se sente en possibilités
si on veut aider quelqu'un de le faire
et non pas de sortir comme avoir la loi
moi j'ai vu comment les crs les traites
et c'est pas vrai qu'ils aident les
associations de bénévoles quand tout
d'un coup il a une rafle à minuit et
qu'il faut ranger tous les trucs et qui
partent dans tous les sens c'est pas
vrai qu'on les aime je vous suggère de
réserver le mot rafle à d'autres
périodes sombres d'un an maintenant
20 ans dont affiche ses positions et a
su que son autre rôle de donneur de
leçons mais tentant j'emmène des bonnes
elles seront plus dans ton journal de
mauvaises mais j'aime bien mais j'aime
fédérer j'aime rassembler et j'aime
partager c'est la chose que j'aime le
plus au monde on peut me levant en
pleine crise sanitaire l'acteur fait
part de ses craintes avant le
confinement y avait un bruit qui courait
lettres allaient devenir meilleurs et en
fait non j'ai l'impression qu'on a
repris nos mauvaises habitudes nos
mauvais réflexe c'est ça qui fait le
plus peur et j'ai vécu toute ma vie dans
une dans un monde où les parents se
sacrifie pour les enfants et j'ai
l'impression là qu'on a sacrifié un peu
notre jeunesse pour les parents vincent
lindon président du jury du festival de
cannes cette année fera peut-être
rayonner le cinéma social
[Musique]